مرحبًا، عظيم رؤيتك،
أول شيء تهانينا على الدوحة، كيف
كان ذلك، شكرًا جزيلاً لك، نعم لم يكن من
السهل أبدًا لعب الكثير من البطولات
المتتالية، نعم ولكن تلك كانت خطة، لذا أه،
لديك بداية جيدة هذا العام، نعم،
لم تكن كذلك  كان الأمر سهلاً في الدوحة ولكن بعد الفوز في
روتردام قررت أن تحاول
الحفاظ على الثقة والتمكن من القيام بذلك
هناك، وهذا ما سأحاول القيام به
هنا في دبي نعم بالضبط والآن في
دبي تهدف إلى اللقب الثالث
اه هل تحب اللعب في دبي بشكل
عام لقد لعبت هنا مرتين
وبصراحة لعبت بشكل سيء اه مرة
مرضت حقا في المرة الأولى لذلك كان الأمر على ما
يرام ليس سهلا وفي المرة الثانية خسرت
بسهولة في الجولة الأولى لعبت بشكل سيء للغاية
ولكن  يحدث هذا أحيانًا، كما تعلمون
روتردام على سبيل المثال في المرتين الماضيتين،
خسرت الجولة الأولى هذا العام وتمكنت من
الفوز بالبطولة، لذلك كل عام هو
قصة جديدة أحب أن أكون في دبي للمشاركة في
البطولة وأتطلع إلى
لعب مبارياتي هنا ودبي هي  الأمر
مختلف عن البطولات الأخرى،
هل تشعر أن اللعب في الشرق الأوسط
به شيء مختلف
أم ليس حقًا، يتعلق الأمر عادةً أيضًا
بالظروف إذا تحدثنا فقط عن
ملعب التنس أه أه قليلًا
أود أن أقول ظروف غريبة لأنها
قليلة  صحراوية بعض الشيء ولكن أيضًا رطبة
مع ملح البحر نعم تتفاعل الكرات
غريبًا بعض الشيء وأه ليس من السهل
التعود عليها ولهذا السبب في
بعض الأحيان لم أحب
اللعب في هذه الظروف ولكن
الأسبوع الماضي في الدوحة كان رائعًا ولكن  بشكل
عام، كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى لي في الدوحة،
وكانت تلك هي المرة الأولى لي في دبي، وكانت هذه المرة أكثر قليلاً في دبي.
أحب كلتا المدينتين وأحب أن أكون هنا،
نعم، لذا نعم، أنا أتطلع إلى
البطولة، لذا فقد فزت بأول بطولة كبرى لك
في عام 2010، نعم
[موسيقى  ]
أم أنه يضيف المزيد من الضغط عليك،
لا أعرف، بالتأكيد أنا
سعيد بالتأكيد لأنني تمكنت من القيام بذلك لأنه
شيء سيبقى معي
إلى الأبد ولكني كنت دائمًا متعطشًا
للمزيد لذلك أريد أن أقول  لا أعتقد أن
ذلك يضيف أي ضغط، فقط الثقة،
أعلم أنني قادر على القيام بذلك، أعرف
كيفية القيام بذلك، والسؤال الآخر هو أنك
تحتاج إلى التغلب على الكثير من اللاعبين الجيدين من
أجل تحقيق ذلك وهذا
ليس بالأمر السهل في بعض الأحيان.  نعم نفس الشيء ينطبق على
الترتيب رقم واحد بالعودة إلى
المركز الأول أيضًا هل تشعر بالضغط
أو نفس الشيء نفس الشيء في نفس
الوقت كان الكثير من اللاعبين السابقين يخبرونني
أن
الأمر لم يكن سهلاً بالنسبة لهم وأخيراً عندما
أصبحت رقم واحد ولم ألعب
أفضل ما لدي ثم تراجعت بالتأكيد
في التصنيف لذا لا أعرف ربما حدث
ذلك دون وعي بالتأكيد، بعض وسائل الإعلام
تتوقع الناس منك المزيد،
عن
وعي، لم أفعل ذلك، أردت فقط
الاستمرار  الفوز حتى عندما كنت رقم
واحد أو حتى عندما أكون الآن رقم
سبعة رقم واحد كان أمرًا رائعًا، كما تعلم،
كنت سعيدًا بتحقيق هذا المركز
لأن تصنيفات التنس عادلة جدًا،
فكلما زاد عدد النقاط التي تحصل عليها، كلما ارتفع
تصنيفك.
لذا، نعم، ليس هناك الكثير
لأضيفه إليه، لذلك عندما كنت في المركز الأول كان لا
يزال لدي الكثير من النقاط من العام الماضي
ولم أتمكن من اللعب بشكل جيد، لذا
تراجعت والآن أحاول العودة،
نعم  لقد ذكرت بالفعل من قبل أن
الزواج ساعدك في لعبة التنس والآن بعد أن
أصبحت أبًا جديدًا، تهانينا على ذلك
الذي سيضيف أيضًا إلى لعبة التنس الخاصة بك
أو سيغير التنس أو
نمط حياتك أو من
الصعب القول لأن نمط الحياة
يتغير بالتأكيد ولكن الجميع يعرف ذلك
الأطفال يغيرون نمط حياتهم نعم، التنس
ما زال يريد الفوز ولأكون صادقًا لكوني
أبًا، لقد فزت بالفعل بثلاثة ألقاب،
لذا آمل أن يساعدك ذلك على معرفة ذلك ولكن
النتيجة على الأقل هي هكذا، لذلك
أنا سعيد بذلك وأنا سعيد نعم  لكي
أكون أبًا، كيف ساعدني الزواج
أيضًا آسف كيف ساعدني الزواج
أيضًا آه نعم لقد ساعدني على
النمو وهو ما أعتقد آه نعم كنت
بحاجة إليه لممارسة رياضة التنس، لقد ساعدني ذلك على
الفهم نوعًا ما  آه، ما أريده من الحياة
ولعب التنس الجيد كان أحد هذه
الأشياء وقد فهمت نوعًا ما كيفية
القيام بذلك بشكل أفضل،
دائمًا ما يكون لديك ردود أفعال مثيرة للاهتمام
عندما تفوز،
دائمًا ما يكون الأمر كما لو كان الناس
ينتظرون فوزك، كيف سيكون رد فعله، كما
تعلم  هل تخطط لهذه الأشياء أم أنها
تحدث في لحظة أم لا، أنا
لا أخطط أبدًا وربما في 95 من الوقت
لا أفعل أي شيء
ولكن أه لهذا السبب نعم لهذا السبب ربما
أفعل شيئًا ما في الخمسة بالمائة من الوقت  يلاحظ الناس في الواقع
ولكن آه نعم، أحب أن تعرف كيفية
إنشاء بعض الأشياء ولكن ليس عن
قصد وأنا لا أفعل ذلك بالتأكيد لإثارة
ضجة كبيرة، فأنا لا أحب هذه الضجة أبدًا
إذا كان بإمكاننا قول مثل هذا لذلك أنا فقط  افعل ذلك
حسنًا، نعم، عادةً ما أفعل ذلك مع فريقي
أو مع أصدقائي، حسنًا، أنت لا تحب أن
تكون مثل الاتجاه السائد أوه لا لا على الإطلاق،
أعلم ذلك بالتأكيد، كلما
لعبت بشكل أفضل، زادت الفرص، وهناك
بعض الفرص الأخرى  الأشياء التي تفعلها تصبح
اتجاهًا بعض الأشياء التي تعرضها وبالطبع
أنا على علم بهذا أه لكن أه نعم
لم أهتم بها كثيرًا أبدًا ولكن الضجيج والشعبية
حققت
الترتيب الأول حققت البطولات الأربع الكبرى ما الذي
يحفزك على القيام بذلك  المزيد لتحقيق المزيد
ما الذي ترغب في تحقيقه أعتقد أن
الرياضة بشكل عام في التنس الشيء هو
أن كل أسبوع يمكنك تحقيقه هو أسبوع جديد، لذا
إذا خسرت أسبوعًا قبل أن تتاح لك
الفرصة الأسبوع المقبل إذا كنت تريد
الأسبوع الذي يسبقك  يجب أن أستمر على هذا
النحو في الأسبوع المقبل وهذا ليس بالأمر السهل وهذا ما
يحفزني، أريد فقط
أن أكون أفضل نسخة تنس لنفسي، وهناك
الكثير من
لاعبي التنس الجيدين جدًا، وهذه
نقطة مثيرة للاهتمام قلت إنني أريدها  أكون
أفضل نسخة من نفسي لأنهم
يحاولون دائمًا مقارنتك باللاعبين الآخرين
أو مثل الماعز الذين
يسمونهم الآن ويريدون دائمًا
إخبارك أوه هل تشعر أنك تريد
مهنة هذا أو ذاك لكنك لا تفعل ذلك  "من
الواضح أنني لا أريد مسيرة أي منهم،
نعم بالتأكيد، أريد فقط أن أفعل
ما بوسعي وأحاول أن أبذل قصارى جهدي للتأكد من أننا
سنرتكب أخطاء، لذلك ربما
قبل عام واحد لم ألعب بشكل جيد، ربما ارتكبت
بعض الأخطاء".  ما زلت غير متأكد من
الأمر ولكني دائمًا أبذل قصارى جهدي وهذا هو
الأهم بالنسبة لي، لذلك عندما
أنهي مسيرتي المهنية أقول إنني لست نادمًا على ذلك، لقد
فعلت ما بوسعي والآن حان الوقت للحياة الجديدة،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، أتمنى ذلك.  أنت
الأفضل في دبي، لذا سيكون لديك في الدوحة
ودبي حظًا موفقًا أيضًا،
شكرًا لك